Appreciate your insight. We will transition to Department of Neighborhoods
and their workshop. At this time, I'd like to welcome director Takarsha
Francis and Herbert Sims to the podium.
Thank you, everyone, for showing up officially.
Good afternoon, Director Francis.
You welcome.
Thank you. Good afternoon, Mr. Chair. Mayor Pretem,
as well as the other council members and representatives,
our mayor in his absence, as well as those who are viewing by HTV
and our public speakers today. I am Takasha Francis, the proud
director of the Department of Neighborhoods for the City of Houston,
and I'm here to discuss our proposed Department of Neighborhoods
FY 23 operating budget. Now, before I do that,
I want to first of all acknowledge the men and women of the Department of
Neighborhoods who could not be here today, but provide excellent,
stellar service to Houstonians every single day. My personal
message to them, as I tell them often, is how much I appreciate their professionalism,
their flexibility, and their ability to do so
much with so little. But I mostly appreciate that they are true
public servants. So thank you guys for everything that you do.
Of course, no team is complete without leadership, and I want to start
off by acknowledging some of our leadership today. To my immediate
right is one of my assistant directors, Mr. Herbert Sims, who is also our Finance
Manager. I'd like to ask the following leaders to also stand as I
call their names. Our Assistant Director, Mr. Reggie Harris,
who is present with us, who oversees our Inspections and Public
Services division. Our finance Manager
has already been acknowledged. Our pio,
Evangelina Behill, is behind you all, taking wonderful pictures that
you'll see later on in our social media channels. Mr.
Mark Cueva is our senior staff analyst, who is also present
with us. Ms. Mulaney, Morris and Joel Aguere are our administrative
coordinators in the director's office. And now on
to our division managers who are also present. Ms. Rhonda. Saudder,
Division Manager of the Mayor's Assistance Office mr.
Victor Gonzalez, who is the Division manager of the Mayor's Office of
Gang Prevention and Intervention. Mr. Terrence O'Neill,
division Manager of the Office of New Americans and Immigrant Communities.
And last but not least, Mr. Paul Green, the Office of Neighborhood
Engagement. These leaders are to be commended, and I thank them for
being partners with me every single day as we deliver these
services to the City of Houston. Found on the next slide. Next slide,
please. We begin today's presentation
with a snapshot of our functional organizational chart. As you'll notice,
this chart includes both personnel and operational expenditures
to comply with the performance based budget criteria and format. Our divisions
and expenditures are placed into several programs. You'll also
notice a subtle change in our program titles. First with the
Mayor's Office of Gang Prevention and Intervention which houses our
antigang programming and grant funded auxiliary programs
such as Gang Victims Federal Grant Program Early Intervention Services
and Harris County Probation Gang Intervention and Prevention Program.
You'll also see that we've added the Office of Neighborhood Engagement.
This office was created by transferring five FTEs out
of the Director's Office, so it is a net neutral move. There is no
additional cost, and it is focused primarily on the Department's community
programming and civic participation. The programs housed in
this division include, but are not limited to complete communities University
the Mayor's Youth Council Volunteer Initiatives, a month
of Service program, the upcoming Signbusters program,
council Member Alcohorn and Neighborhood Matching Grants Next
slide, please. Now, the departmental
programming for the Department of Neighborhoods houses four major
service areas residential Code Enforcement,
Community Engagement and Neighborhood Initiatives,
citizenship Assistance and Language Access and Gang
Prevention and intervention services. Now, each slide
will outline our major services, the statutory
requirements, additional financial grant funded support,
and then the financial and or societal impact for each service.
Now, for Brevity, I will touch on the service and the financial
and societal impact, and I will reference funding
when applicable. But I will stand open for any questions if you have them thereafter.
Starting with the Residential Code Enforcement Division. This is our largest and
most outward facing division. Please note the statutory
requirements and grant funding listed this year. We have 26
Code Enforcement officers and inspector positions
budgeted on the General Fund. 43 Code Enforcement Officer
and inspector positions are budgeted under CDBG grant funds.
However, in fiscal year 22, we were greatly affected
by an increase in turnover and so. Currently, we have a 19%
vacancy rate on the General Fund and a 28% vacancy
rate including grant funds. So what we have is a total of
69 budgeted Code Enforcement Officer positions that
equates to 50 boots on the ground and 19
vacancies. When we look at the financial next
slide, please. When we look at the financial
and societal impact of this particular service area,
residential Code Enforcement carries both financial and societal
impacts. Blight such as dilapidated structures,
high weeds, and junk motor vehicles continue to pose a major threat
to public health and safety. Societal impacts include
safer healthier communities with less crime,
urban decay, and increases economic vitality
and opportunity. The financial impacts of Code enforcement
mirror those social impacts and also include a lowered maintenance
cost for these Blighted properties, increased property values,
and tax collections. However, the rising cost to
abate Blighted properties due to more expensive labor and supplies,
including fuel, primarily may increase the
city's expenses. Next slide, please.
Our next service area is Gang Prevention and Intervention, which is
housed within the Mayor's Office of Gang Prevention and Intervention.
Most notably, this division oversees programs that promote awareness,
build resistance skills, and educate on the dangers of gang involvement
and juvenile delinquency. Please note the statutory requirements
and the additional support and impact.
Next slide, please.
The next service area is our Community Engagement and Neighborhood
Initiatives. This area refers to two of our areas
the Mayor's Assistance Office and the Office of
Neighborhood Engagement. Please take note of the statutory requirements
and additional financial support. Now of course,
as we've noted previously, we changed the Mayor's Assistance Office
from the Mayor's Citizens Assistance Office to be more inclusive
of all residents in the City of Houston. I'm very proud of our
one of a kind collaboration of workshops and community program through
the Office of Neighborhood Engagement. And I also would like to take this moment
to acknowledge our Citizenship Assistance and Language access
services through the Office of New Americans and Immigrant Communities.
And it is a thriving program that is utilized throughout the City
and a major component of citizenship assistance.
Now, when we look at the financial and societal impact of all three
of these service delivery areas social programming such as youth
prevention and intervention services, super neighborhoods and
citizenship Assistance increase civic engagement,
public awareness and education, and it empowers communities to
advocate and improve their quality of life. We saw that in
the last presentation. These programs provide similar financial impacts
as Code enforcement indirectly over time through implementation
of the various programming and services. I believe my colleague, Chief Samuel
Pena said in his presentation, prevention is key. So these
programs are a way for us to prevent some of the issues by
providing appropriate education to the communities that need them on
how to be good neighbors and how to follow City protocol
and programs. Next slide, please.
Now, as we look at the anticipated growth or reduction in
population serves and how that actually affects our budget, we're always cognizant
of how that will also affect our ability to deliver
services. Now, as the City grows, we have to consider these challenges
to maintain a service level that's not sustainable with our current
budget. As I mentioned before, rising costs,
particularly in labor and supplies fuel
this will affect the number of abatements that can be completed within
the limited budget we've been given. So, for example, as we procure
new Lands and Grounds maintenance and debris removal contracts in the
upcoming fiscal year, we face fuel costs that have increased 55%
since the last contract procurement in 2018.
Currently, Code Enforcement officers are expected to inspect over one
over 13 sq. Mi out of a total
of 627 sq. Mi of the entire city.
And our Community Liaisons average 400,000
residents based on the super neighborhoods they are required
to give services to. So as the City continues
to increase in population, our budgets will get tighter, these numbers
will grow and our services will be stretched. Next slide
please.
Don's revenue is primarily the money that we
collect from liens from Property Abatement Section. Ten,
four, five, three of the City's Municipal Code allows us to
place liens on properties to recoup the City's expenses
as a result of demolitions of dangerous buildings,
weed and debris removal on vacant lots, and securing
properties. We recoup these funds either from voluntary
payment or the legal process of foreclosing on
these liens. Now, you'll notice in this slide a large decrease
in revenue under licenses and permits. The reason for that is that Don
no longer collects the deposit fees that we previously transferred
from Houston Public Works. Next slide,
please. Our revenue highlights
include a projected increase in fiscal year 23 revenue
collection by approximately 8% over FY
22 estimates. The change is a projection based on pandemic
restrictions being eased. Our current revenue collection is
based on trend analysis as well as external variables due to
passive collection methods.
Next slide, please.
Last year, we projected our FY 22 expenditures
to be around $12.4 million, based on
the most recent data we project to hit that mark. Our proposed
budget for FY 23 includes few minor changes,
but overall the proposed budget, which includes a 1% or
126,000 personnel budget increase from FY
22 estimates due to Hope allowances and health care
and pension obligations. So that is the only difference in
what we are presenting today. Next slide, please.
Now, the next slide here provides a snapshot of our personnel versus
nonpersonal expenditures. In the first circle graph,
you'll notice we have personnel expenditures at 68%
of Don's overall budget. The remaining 32
in the second pie graph shows our non personnel
services, which include miscellaneous support services,
supplies and services like computers,
printing, publications, uniforms,
document filing services and then, of course, restricted accounts
as determined by Central Finance, which include fuel,
health insurance, HR, client services and vehicle services.
Next slide, please. Now, slide number
twelve provides a detailed explanation of our expenditure net changes.
One major change was $157,000 for
Hope allowances as well as health benefits and a restricted account
return. Overall, there is little to no change from the FY
22 operating budget. Based on the proposed 2023
budget of 12.6 million. The recent change has
been 1.9% from last year's budget or
the current budget. Next slide, please.
Now, under our expenditure highlights, you'll notice that there is a 15%
increase of restricted accounts. There is 2.3%
reduction in our supplies and service line items.
And then of course, as I mentioned previously, 68% of Don's overall
budget is allocated to personnel expenses.
This concludes my presentation. And before we move to Q and
A, we just like you to take a moment at your leisure to include additional
information in the appendices for your viewing and accomplishment
pleasure. I now stand open for your questions. Thank you, Director Francis.
First up, we will have Council Member Michael Kubosh. Thank you, council member.
Director Francis. That was excellent. Thank you. And your voice
is easy to hear. Thank you very much. Thank you, sir.
Bandit Signs? Yes. Where are we
on trying to get these things removed? Are we writing tickets for
them? Are we just pulling them up? Well, I'm very glad that
you asked that question. So, what we've done since last year council
Member Alcorn reached out personally and wanted to
know about a volunteer Bandit Sign program and so for the last year,
we've been working with Harris County so that we could combine our efforts
and kind of come out of that silo mentality to develop
a volunteer program. Now, one of the things that has actually held
us up is the fact that their bandit sign program, of course, deals with
the ETJ when they have a different statutory requirement for actually
picking up the bandit signs and assessing fines. So what we're doing
right now is trying to put together a program that will allow
a combined training so that volunteers can be trained to
either volunteer in the county or within the city. So let me ask
you, can any citizen safely,
without getting hit by traffic, remove a sign,
a bandit sign, from a median area
in between the roads? You can.
But, Council Member Kubash, I'm smiling because
I have to admit, sometimes I do it well,
but I don't want you to do it. I know, and I'm not going to
do it. Sometimes I want to stop and get stuff out of the road,
but I realize that I might become a part of the road.
So another thing is we're in political season,
the crazy season. Yes. They're sticking these things all over the place.
Absolutely. They're attaching them to road signs, these big four baits,
and we need some.
I see a lot of them in the ETJ as well,
so we need to do something about that. Are we writing these folks citations?
Yes, sir, we are writing citations. You want a picture of them sent to you
or sent in three? One. One. You do whatever you feel is necessary except
pick up that sign. You call me, you tell me, and I'll go over
there and pick it up. But in all seriousness, Council Member Kubosh, we are very
cognizant of the fact that political season is one. Permission to extend?
No, you don't need it. Go ahead. Okay. But I need it so
very quickly because I do realize other people that just means Kubash's time has expired.
Put me back in.
We're working on trying to be a little bit more aggressive in terms of making
sure that we're getting the signs up, hence the volunteer program.
But we're also looking at ways to better educate our candidates
with the importance of being able to go behind. Once you've put
the signs up, please go back and pick them up. So we're working on that,
and we're aware of the issue, but thank you for bringing it to light today.
Vice Mayor Pro TEM Martha Castex Tatum. Thank you,
chair. Director Francis. Thank you for the presentation. Last year,
one of our budget amendments was for each
district to have a code enforcement officer
to work with our individual offices,
and that passed. However, that hasn't happened.
I see that we have quite a few vacancies in the code
enforcement arena. However, I'm very
interested, and I think it would be advantageous
for us as we work to protect neighborhoods alongside the Department of
Neighborhoods, to have a direct contact and
individual code enforcement officer that works with
our office. I liked when we had that individual liaison
that worked with our offices. I know that staffing
is a challenge, but I would like to see us
move towards having someone specific that
we can work with in our offices
to help with the enforcement in our districts.
With all due respect to the mayor's office
and Renee and Rhonda, they do a phenomenal job, but God help
them, there's no way that they can manage the number
of code enforcement issues that we deal in this entire city.
But I know that residents like having that specific person.
I like having a specific person. Is there a way
we can move towards having an individual person
from your office that works with our individual offices
for code enforcement issues? Sure. And actually Vice Mayor
Pro Tim. You currently have one. So I know that you remember,
because you were here when I came in as Director, that we did have a
specific liaison for all of the council members because at
that time, we were about 20,000 cases behind. And so the Mayor's
Assistance Office, that is part of their responsibility to communicate
any issues that you all are having and to basically help you solve the issues
that you're having or that citizens are having in your particular district.
We also have a call number I'm
sorry, a customer service number directly to IPS.
So if there is an issue where citizens, they can call three one one
and then they can follow up. So what I think part of the disconnect might
be, and I'm happy to take this call offline is if
there's another level of service that you're looking for from the liaisons who are
assigned to the super neighborhoods in your district. I'm happy to have that conversation
so that we can be more efficient in how we are actually communicating.
And I will go back and take another look at that budget amendment regarding a
specific code enforcement officer to each district, because currently
our code enforcement officers, as I mentioned before, there are 50
on the ground. We do have vacancies that are available, but I think every
director will share with you all that the city has not been immune to the
great resignation, nor have we been immune to people
having other options that they choose to pursue. In code enforcement,
unfortunately, is not at the top of that list. Nor is
our salary competitive enough. So that's another issue that
we'd like to kind of deal with. But I'm happy to take that conversation offline,
have a more specific conversation about what your office is looking for,
and then we can make sure our liaisons are making
those adjustments. Okay. And then the other question I'll put you back
in queue, if you don't mind. You have you 1 minute of fame. I gave
you three. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Yes. Thank you, Chair. And thank you, Director. I want to get a good handle
on the number of inspectors that you have. You said 56 out
of the general fund. It looks like you're including 53
in code enforcement in this budget. Then you
said 43 are from CDBG.
Okay. So we're not getting more.
You have 19 vacancies. Are those all within the general fund or were
those CDBG or combined? How many
do you want to have total? From the general fund?
Yeah, you need to have 300, but you've got about nine.
Sure. So according to my notes
here, we have 69 budgeted positions.
From the general fund or from both? That and CDBG? For both. Okay. For both?
For both. All right. And out
of those 69 positions, 26 are general fund, 43 are CDBG
funded. Okay. In looking at your performance measures, I'm just
curious if you're going to keep the same amount or you're hopefully going to fill
the vacancies. I mean, I'm sure you're actively pursuing people to fill
these vacancies. Sure. Because you're talking about going from 250
daily inspections to 350 daily inspections. Yes.
You're talking about junk motor vehicles removed
last year. You had a target of 3500. You guys got to
860. You're doubling that for next year.
I'm looking at weeded lots. You want to go from 10,000
this year to 15,000. And my question is
just simply how are you going to do that without
adding significantly to the number of inspectors?
And I appreciate that question. The first thing I'd like to point out,
and I'm thankful that you have actually made that picture a lot more clearer,
is that our code enforcement staff has
been able to do a phenomenal job considering the fact that we
don't have enough code enforcement officers. And in order for them to do that,
that means a lot of double work, double areas,
which is part of the reason why we can't necessarily dedicate in
one particular place. What I can say to you, Council Member Alcorn,
is that we will continue to work assiduously to bring in
code enforcement officers. But let me be very blunt about what we've experienced
in the last year. We've had a lot of people sign on and
then they leave within a month. So whether it's been
I don't know if it's that they just had a different idea of what the
job was, maybe they got out in the heat and decided they didn't want to
do it. But we have not had people. The turnover has been
considerable. So what I can tell you that
we are attempting to do to reach this goal has
really been not only with our inspections, but with our Abatement budget.
We have become much more aggressive about correcting the issues through
our Abatement budget in addition to giving notification
to recalcitrate property owners, because ultimately, at the end of the day,
communities want it corrected. They don't really care
about the inspection. They just want to wake up and not see this lot next
door. So part of what we are looking to do in terms of accomplishing
that feat, which is what we have done in terms, of course, correction over the
last few years is focused more on the correction side, which is
why our ability to recoup on the lien foreclosure side
instead of relying on passive people that just come in and decide to pay the
money. We have to become more aggressive as a city in going after
the money that we're putting out. So that's how we plan to do that.
Council Member Amy Pick. Thank you, Chair. And thank
you, Director. Kind of similar to Council Member Alcorn's question about
inspections. You talked about the anticipated growth and the constraints
there. Do you have goals as far as what the turnaround time will be for
inspections for this next fiscal year and not just the first inspection, but also
the look back inspections as well? Well, as you
know, council Member part of the ability to go back and do
the check back inspections that we do after the initial really depends
on the bodies we have on the ground. So what we're trying to do now
as we're looking at our positions is trying to figure out how we can possibly
go back and reconfigure
our ability to go back and do those. But I'll be very honest with you.
Based on the limited amount of people we have, I don't see those times changing.
What I can say to you, however, is that we have now started
utilizing under the code an emergency provision. Because, sadly,
so many of the vacant lots that we have or some of the dilapidated
buildings that we have in our communities are in such
disrepair and are so high that they actually qualify
through our emergency abatements, which are given to us under the
code. And so one of the focuses that we've done at
this particular point now hasn't been as much of a focus so much on
the checkback inspections, but really looking at our inventory,
what breaches the emergency threshold and really trying to address those
a lot faster. So it has a tangential effect on our ability
to get back around. So even if we're not able to get back on a
checkback inspection, if something rolls on our radar that is emergency
level, then we address that with a level of priority.
So I hope that answers the question a little better.
Yes, thank you. And in the interest of time, I'll just put the rest on
SharePoint. Thank you. Council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you. Thank you. Director, the number around the bandit
signs, does that include the solid? Excuse me? The hotspot
team, their work in districts, do they contribute
to this 45,000 or is this your team exclusively?
No, this was our team. Wow. So this number could actually be higher in terms
of like, collective effort? Possibly, yes.
Council Member Michael Kubosh. Thank you very much. Good to
see you. Reggie Harris. I guess I've known you about 25
years. It's good to see you.
The electronic ticket writing process that we,
years ago, we passed, I can't remember what it was
called, electronic ticket writing. Or are you speaking
of us moving from paper to N four?
N four. Are we using N four today? Oh, absolutely.
We're not the only ones. It's actually we've influenced the fire department
to come on to N four, as well as, I think, some aspects of public
works. So it's working very well for us. And what about parking and
handicapped parking spots?
Is that under your department writing? I was going to say I'm going to defer
to my colleague, Director Tina Pius, on that. Well, that's her wheelhouse.
The other thing is, what legislation are you looking at that
maybe the legislature could pass that could help our Department
of Neighborhoods to properly function or function better
in Houston? I think the Legislature, the last
time we actually submitted and supported legislation, it was around higher fines
so that there would be more of a financial
impact to most property owners, most recalcitrant
property owners in many of our communities, Council Member Kubash,
are actually businesses that are just land grabbing and holding. It's not the
average everyday Houstonian. So that was something that we
were very supportive of. And I believe that that was legislation through Senator
Miles's office and I believe State Representative theory previously
moved for higher fines. Really, where the department is going
to be, I think most benefited is looking at our
Abatement budget. And Mayor Turner has been very gracious
in giving us additional money when we've asked for it so that we could be
more proactive on the Abatement side. But I think to couple with
that, again, the city has to be more aggressive in recouping its
money legally once we put it out, because otherwise
we're just putting good money after bad and people rely on us to just
do something they should be doing themselves. Thank you for your service. Thank you,
council Member Kubash. Administration. Regulatory affairs. Budget presentation
is Thursday at 230. Council member or vice
mayor. Pro TEM martha Castex Tatum. Thank you.
Chair Director Francis, what's the pay for a code enforcement
officer? Currently? The starting pay, I believe, is what,
35? Yeah, it's about 35
for a trainee, and you
go up from there for one, two, and a three. By the time you get
to a three, you're looking at a little over 2000 bi
weekly pay. And I think it's 35 with salary.
Thousand dollars and including benefits,
is it not? And we just gave an increase, so it's probably closer to 38
now, a hard fault increase. So I know you all looking
at us like that seems quite low, but that's a recent increase
on top of that. Yes. What's the
average payout in other cities? Are we competitive with
other cities? Are we way below we're not. As a matter of fact,
what I can do, I'll take that as a homework assignment and send that to
you on SharePoint. But what I can tell you is that we're not competitive with
other cities and we're not even competitive within the city. We lose some of
our code enforcement officers to Public Works, who also
offer similar requirements for higher pay for
commercial buildings. What's the requirement? To be a code enforcement officer.
To be a code enforcement officer here in the state of Texas, it is a
state certified program that we pay for coming in.
I believe that program is one year. And then after that, they're actually moved into
a code enforcement officer position. Now, Public Works has
different types of code enforcement officers that deal with different
parts of building codes, and that may have a different requirement,
but this specific requirement is state certified.
Okay. And then my other ask that if you could on
page 19, I like the accomplishments list.
Is there any way that that can be broken down per district?
And page 19,
page 20. I love all the statistics.
Specifically, what's helpful for me, if we can have
those numbers district broken down
by district, we can accommodate that. Okay.
Thank you. Vice Chair Edward Pollard.
Thank you, Mayor Pro Tim. And thank you all for your presentation. When we're talking
about the code enforcement officers, are there any
ways in which we can better utilize our Hot
team personnel to help with picture
taking, to help with any type of code enforcement or any
of that process? It seems like when our Hot teams are out there in
the neighborhoods already servicing
our residents, they're able to see things that
may be in violation or be able to take pictures to send
in. Is there a way in which
we could be more efficient and be able to utilize them in
a manner that will help your department more honestly? Council Member
the fact that you all have Hot teams in place is helpful.
We really don't need any additional help in the reporting area because we get over
51,000 calls through three one one. So we're aware
we've got the reporting part down. What we do have issues
in, I think, as I've mentioned previously, is that while the Hot teams can do
a certain level of the Abatement side of our work, the actual code
enforcement side is a specialized skill and profession that, unfortunately,
you all are not able to do. And so in order for us to do
our job as under chapter ten, which is to go out and give the
official notices and then to write the citations, and hopefully the
citations will be yeah, can they help with that?
Is there a way what is the training entail? Like, how much training is
involved in that? Oh, well, sure. It's no. Problem?
Well, first and foremost, I I think think what you're asking is, are they qualified
to also be code enforcement officers? What can we do to certify
them as such so that you can have more personnel? They can't be certified
outside of the Department of Neighborhoods? They would have to be employees of this department,
because under the code into the city's charter, this department
is the one that actually works specifically for that area. So if they
become code enforcement officers, they'd have to become employees of this department
to do that. And right now, they are employees
of solid waste, I believe.
So through attempt service.
Yeah. It just seems like these are things that we should be able to be
more creative with when it comes to utilizing
personnel more efficiently to streamline the
process. So if we can have some type of overview
on what, in a hypothetical sense,
could be done to utilize our code enforcement officers, to utilize
our hot team to assist with code enforcement, that would be helpful.
And I'd love to continue that conversation, but just let
me reiterate that the work your teams are already doing is helpful.
Yeah, I understand it may be helpful, but we want to find
ways to have more enforcement without
having to maybe go through the same traditional means of
having to hire more code enforcement officers. Or if you're
saying that the average pay is, like, 35,000 and that's below standard,
well, what can we do with the people who are already out there in the
neighborhoods to help? Possibly we
could look at an opportunity for you to use
some of your CDSF funds towards a particular team for your
area, but they would become employees of the Department of Neighborhoods that we would train,
and then they could be specific to your area. That's an opportunity.
Okay, well, let's keep discussing it. Absolutely. All right. Thank you, council Member
Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And apologies for my tardiness.
I, one wanted to first recognize and thank
your team, and I know that Jack and Rhonda specifically
work within our district very heavily,
but to everyone I know, everyone's short staffed and things of that nature,
my staff may have already asked this. If not,
I'm asking every department this question. Okay.
Due to the financial constraints and
challenges that the city continues to face from
revenue caps, from other budgetary issues,
what are the needs that you are not
able to address right now in the department that you would like to
see address or feel that there is a need for? I think
the overwhelming theme at this point, council Member, is the
funds put towards abatement and correction.
Realistically, for a city the size of Houston, 50 code
enforcement officers is abysmal,
and we need more boots on the ground. But realistically,
we're not going to get an additional 200 people tomorrow.
So I'm not banging that drum today. However, the drum
I will bang is that we have been very effective in utilizing our Abatement
funds to be able to correct the issues, to lean those properties.
And I think internally, our ability to do that and have
the funds there to correct those issues and then also making sure that as
a city, that we are foreclosing on these liens and recouping that money
may actually create the revenue we need to bring in the additional bodies down
the line. So that would be my response. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. We have seven total
speakers, public speakers signed up, only one virtual.
So I'm not sure how we're going to do with the in person one,
but we'll start with Mr. Doug Smith. Okay.
Do we need to move? Do you need us to move, Mr okay.
Star six, can you hear me? Yes, we can hear you.
Okay. Sorry about the sorry about the camera earlier.
I had turned it off and logged out and forgot
to turn it back on. But apologize.
This department probably is the one
I care about most because I care about my neighborhood so much.
And I am going to ask today for some council member
to submit an amendment to the budget to add
some employees, maybe several employees, maybe ten, or maybe 20
employees. When you look at the budget, nearly every other department
is adding employees, and this department is cutting full
time equivalents. And I don't understand, given the results
of their statistics on page 520,
why they're not doing this. It's almost like we don't care
about the neighborhoods, which I know is not the case. And also,
you talked about enforcing Abatement the end of last
year, you had $150,000,000 in unpaid liens.
That whole process for me, from having personally
lived through it this year with the junk trailer that you all know about,
is you don't have enough teeth in that process,
and you need to do something about that to improve it.
So how would you address those two things?
Mr. Smith, was that question directed at me?
Yes or council members? Either or
yes. I certainly am going to address why are
we not asking? I would
recommend working with your council member to put an amendment through and identify a
funding source.
Okay. But I do want to ask her why she
didn't ask for more employees when every other department is getting substantial
FTEs.
Okay. So, Mr. Smith, I apologize.
Please repeat your last question, and I'm happy to answer it.
He wants to know why your FTEs drops. And I think in your presentation,
you answered it and you said that you were not competitive with salary. Until we
do something about that, we're not going to be able to attract them.
Am I correct? Yes. Okay. Yes, that will be correct. You limited three positions
in order to make those increases happen. Thank you, Mr. Sims.
Jason Oliver?
Yes. You may want to step back
and go over where your team.
Okay, thank you. All right.
Thank you. So hi. Thank you.
I agree with Doug. The Department of Neighborhoods
is really important, and I hear year after year, right. We need hundreds
of code enforcement officers. We need really hundreds
of people doing the assistance office and literally, like,
everything. And so
I want to follow up on what what Doug asked in terms of how
do you decide what to ask for in
terms of asking for a smaller number instead of
asking for a larger budget for this fiscal year and
more personnel? And then I'm looking at your
budget for the kind of gang prevention salaries is
lower than any actuals from the past five years, and then over
25% lower than, like, five years ago. The actuals
what does this significant decrease mean for service delivery
when there's a big need, particularly right now, for more youth programs?
And then I just want to say we have people who are
showing up to speak just in person. And I know
that was trying to figure out how do people sign up if they
show up to speak in person before the meeting, who do
they go to? They have a write in sheet over
there on the front right side of the room. Okay, perfect.
That's good to know. Thank you. Okay, so first
question, Mr. Oliver. And actually, it might be a little bit easier let's switch,
if you don't mind. I don't want to do that. Come on up, Mr.
Oliver. I want to answer your question directly, so while you're coming up, how we
determine our priorities. As a department director, it's my
responsibility to, of course, look at the needs of my department,
but also as a I'm Team
Don all day. Right. But I am also a part
of Team City of Houston, so I have to not only be familiar
with what the needs are in my department, but I have to be able to
look at the broader landscape of where the priorities of the city are, and I
don't determine those. And so to your point about why
I've not asked for additional money this year
for additional code enforcement officers is because,
as you've mentioned before, every year I mentioned the need for that.
And so I am confident that where we are able to
make those concessions within the overall picture of the budget, the administration
sees an opportunity. We keep a constant conversation throughout the year
about this. So this isn't the only time I bang the drum. If those funds
have become available and there are ways that we can do that to bring on
additional people, then those are things that I've worked with the administration
to do, which is why we actually have more positions now.
Unfortunately, as I mentioned before, we are not able to be
as competitive as we would like to be. And not to mention the fact that
this is a particular area where most people kind
of happen into it. So one of the things that I've talked to my team
about is where we may need to up our recruitment game to let people know
that this is another opportunity that they can look at as a paraprofessional
opportunity. So it's not for lack of
caring about that, but it's also just the fact that when I
look at the grand scheme of the city's needs, I'm not saying our
needs are not important, but I'm also realistic in what I can
ask for at what particular time, and as I'm setting the priorities for the
office. As I mentioned before to Vice Mayor Pro TEM, when we receive concerns
from citizens like you and other people, ultimately you
don't care if someone is inspected five or six times. What you want
is I don't want to see it anymore. I want it corrected.
So what is more attainable at this time is to actually get
more money towards my budget to correct and for us to actually put
more emphasis on the city, recouping those funds so that I can have a
long game approach to bringing in more revenue to my department, to be
able to bring in the people that I need based on revenue that's not available
now. Thank you. Thank you. Your time
has expired, and then it comes back.
I don't think you'll find of the 23 departments that will present any department
that says they have more than enough money to do the proper job
that they were signed up to do. Aris Brown vicky
martin saba
Blanding Hi.
Good afternoon. Yeah, I don't have to hit mute. Six star
six. Okay. The Office of New Americans has a very small
budget. We've all established, and you've
talked about how hard you're working with little staff and not
enough compensation. I think we can do better. City of Houston,
what needs have you seen for immigrant communities during the pandemic that more
resources could help you all address? Wow. So,
needless to say, I think that we've seen an increase in needs,
especially with Title 42 and the Biden administration looking
at a review of that. We are facing up to
maybe 15,000 migrants possibly crossing the border.
So what we have been able to do with the Office of New Americans
and immigrant communities, we have great relationships with our nonprofit partners who
actually facilitate a lot of the programming that we're able to do.
Needless to say, to help corroborate what you mentioned earlier,
we could definitely always use additional staff, but what we're doing right now
is really just trying to use our nonprofit partnerships as a force multiplier
to meet the needs of our immigrant community. And right now,
that is the biggest and most pressing issue that we have before us right now.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Ms. Blinding. Joe.
Rochelle, did I pronounce that correctly?
You did. Thank you. Hi.
Thank you for your presentation. I very much appreciate it. Thank you.
Following on what Council Member Acorn said, you spoke about turnover.
Yes. So how do you plan to address the turnover and keep
the people that you already have? Since I understand that we don't have
competitive salary, and you had mentioned too, about how
are people too hot when they're out there, what are those different things? How do
you prevent, try and keep the people that you already have?
Well, one of the things that is always essential for me as a director is
to always tell people thank you. That goes a long way. And public servants
don't always feel appreciated for what they do. So we definitely
want to make sure that they feel appreciated and not overlooked day to day.
More practically, what we have been able to do is, as Mr.
Sims, my assistant director, mentioned earlier, we have been
able to use some of our vacancies to move forward in some promotion
opportunities. Because at this point, looking at what we're
dealing with collectively as a country coupled with inflation, my mind
has turned more towards retention because I have amazing staff
and invaluable people. So we're looking at different
ways to reward those individuals who are already
doing the job of two people or more. And that's what
we're planning to do, as well as look at another way as a department,
we could be stronger on recruiting people to this profession. Thank you.
Let me see. Thank you, Ms. Grochell. Mr. Butler.
You're welcome,
Director. Hi. Good afternoon. Hi. My name is Broderick Butler. I'm from
northeast Houston. And because of the time, I'm just going to sort
of get to it. I'm going to read my questions and
the three minutes that I have, and I'll let the director 1 minute. Yes.
Sorry. So basically, you have a backlog of cases,
yes or no? You've clarified vacancies
were due to the high turnover rate, not resignations.
So how are you able to complete your goal without putting a burden on
remaining employees? Would more inspectors be assigned to specific
designated areas, such as Council Member Tatum suggested, instead of rotating
them be better due to your high number of turnover? It was pointed out
to me that it appears this is an all hands on deck situation at dawn.
Has senior management staff considered interacting with the public?
And those are the questions that I have, because the way this
is set up, it looks like a potential failure. I don't think that they will
fail, but it is set up to where if you
don't have enough to get the job done at the end of the day,
regardless, it puts you in a very difficult situation,
Mr. Butler. So we have backlog of cases,
more inspectors, and interaction with public.
Got it. So no problem. Thank you so much. Do we have
a backlog in our cases? Actually, we are current, according to
the mayor's dashboard, I believe, at 90 some odd
percent in terms of our performance measures and meeting the first inspection.
So because we don't have enough people, we do have a backlog
of our Abatement cases. So once we've inspected and
go back out, then we definitely have a backlog there. How are we going
to deal with that? I'm going to utilize my current budget to spend what needs
to be spent to correct it and ask for additional funds if they are available.
When you mentioned before, vacancies are due high to turnover rates and
not resignations. Yes, turnover is because people have been kind of coming in and
going back out, and this is not something that is particular
to the Department of Neighborhoods currently. Our country is dealing with a great resignation
where people are looking for different opportunities with more flexibility that,
quite frankly, this particular role cannot offer. When you're
looking at how do we complete our goals without putting a burden on remaining
employees, we absolutely cannot complete our goals without putting an additional burden
on everybody, and that includes me. So all of us are working several positions
so that we can accomplish what we're needing to accomplish. And that's why I
love my team, because they do it from a great place and a love of
community. They're very flexible, and they do the extra that is required.
Would Morris inspectors be assigned to specific designated areas?
Absolutely. If I had the inspectors that I would ideally like
to have, every area, every district, every neighborhood would have a specific
team. But because I do not, then we have to put them where the need
is greatest, and we have to rotate them as necessary.
It is an all hands on deck situation. Senior management
staff is always interacting with the public, and if you
have not seen us enough, let me know, and I will come and see you
myself. Personally, however, it's always an on
hands on deck situation with Don. But what I'm happy to
report is that we put all hands, feet, fingers, and toes in
the work that we need to get done. Thank you. With all due respect,
though, I unfortunately do not see that in my community as I speak
to citizens as we go about our daily business.
But I always hope that one people can do better.
Thank you. Thank you so much. And I invite you to visit with me at
your leisure so we can talk about your specific issues. In what area?
Northeast Houston. Cynical at 77016.
Thank you so much. Ms. Melissa Martinez.
Hi, how are you? Good afternoon,
everyone. Good afternoon. I have a couple of questions I'm
interested in overall, just on accessibility,
on how to make the Neighborhoods grants more accessible, and who has
the authority to change the nonprofit eligibility requirement for neighborhood
grants? So that's my first, and then I have a second. Why do the
neighborhood grants operate on a reimbursement model? And who has the
authority to change that as well? By requiring people to pay out of pocket.
It significantly limits the applicant pool. And I want to add more context
to that, that for folks in communities.
Not everyone has the same background, whether it's academic or
salary wise, to be able who want to create change of
a project within their own district. And that
is why I'm interested in with these questions on how we can invest in our
community members to have the ability to create change in their own
backyards and not just in other proposals
for more. To me,
that is public safety. Okay, that's a fair question.
So the requirements around neighborhood matching grants,
at one point in time prior to my coming on as director, there was a
specific pool of money that was given to the department to actually deliver
this program. As I understand it, it's always been a reimbursable program
where we're matching funds that are coming in from the community. I do understand
your concern about that not being as accessible for some individuals. However,
what I found is that when people have teeth in the game, they tend to
be a little bit better about maintaining and organizing and actually keeping
up those beautification processes. The other part is that because
now we don't currently have that pot of money, what we do to keep the
program going is we assist the council members offices,
which is the source of funding. So the source of funding for
our matching grant program now comes from the council district service funds.
The council members choose the projects that they would like to or can afford
to actually fund for that year.
And because of the fact that these are taxpayer
dollars, there's a specific way that we have to actually deal with taxpayer
dollars, which means we can't give that out to individuals. It would have to be
the nonprofit protections that are offered, which is the reason why it is specific
to 501 C, three S in receiving the money. So we're not trying
to make it extra difficult, but legally, we have certain parameters we have
to follow as a city if we're going to put taxpayer dollars towards a specific
project. So I hope that answers your question. Thank you.
Question thank you.
No, ma'am, your time has expired. Thank you. You can submit the question
in writing, and we will have the
ability to have your council member get back in touch with
you. Okay. So before we dismiss
Vice Mayor Pro TEM martha Castex Tatum. Yes. I just have one more question.
Do we have any code enforcement officers that work on weekends?
No. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. But that's a great idea. One, we've been working for it,
and as you said to your people thank you.
Thank you to you and Director Sims and all your staff. So thank you.
Thank you, Chair. And another reminder, public,
if you have questions, you can always locate those into
your council members and then you'll have the ability for them to
provide the additional response back to you. So thank you. Thank you.